we got somebody that's running for
office
sorry folks it's a big deal around these
parts god i'd love to
test the effectiveness of that vest
all right
oh i was going to say do you think you
have to actually oh wait can we address
this please
please okay so the other night on night
wave i was playing his comeback video
which he does every end of every january
because yeah
says it everything the buy rates are
down in january and uh
he was like updating people and at one
point in the video he goes
we've got a lot of changes come in we
got landau joining us
and i'm like there's no way he's talking
about dave landau i'm like dude there
can't
there he cannot possibly be talking
about dave landau
and the whole chat was going oh yeah
yeah yeah it's dave landau he's leaving
compound it's dave land out i'm going
like i was picturing this bidding war
happening over
dave landau but um boy
you guys were right it's it's really as
dave landau left to go work for crowder
so landau left the compound and some
he's also moved he must have moved from
new york to
to texas too for this job he had to have
because that's really crap
his family this time i don't know um
so what is he like is he crowder's like
second mic or something
hi guys no i'm just curious is that what
he's supposed to be
by the way what a shitty spot to have to
sit like
if you're part of the show it's like
you're sitting in a little guest chair
you have to actually guess do you think
that in like 20 30 years from now
we'll be looking back at this time where
do you think we'll be saying
remember when we let uh boys beat up
girls and sports and
remember one pretended that steven
crowder was funny yeah remember that
but people said there were 52 genders
boy that was a weird phase or do you
think we'll just
actually continue on down that trail and
the idea because it's because
it is it flies in the face of biology
and science do you think there'll be a
correction on that i think in 20 years
i'll be like
it's so crazy how that world ended eight
years ago
i can't believe we're all still here
roach
they're still around i mean why did that
get such a
i don't really know landau i'll be
honest with you i don't know if he's
funny or not i really don't know because
i don't really watch that stuff so maybe
he's a funny dude i have no idea
so this is like my first real because i
don't really watch compound shows
i hate morning zoo like
that's a good one i i am hopeful but i
think we're at
kind of a tipping point with that you
know he's mad because before the landau
was on he was like the second mike guy
oh yeah you know you're like
shut up producer yeah it's gonna go one
way or the other where it will either
correct back or we're just going to
continue on and i think we're kind of at
that point where if people can
tie my prediction is that in two months
dave landau will be tim poole's new
coast oh that'd be great
of a social kind of cultural fabric too
yeah but then you have to take your
shoes off
to donald trump and an outmoded
conservatism
if they can do that effectively hating
against those then yes they can keep
that and the trajectory will continue
but if we can have some people come in
and espouse conservative values and not
get tarred and feathered
they will be targeted by the bigot well
for being a bigot right
yeah but i think it's a little bit
bigger i don't think so either but he
gave he
he made it easy for them i don't think
he's gonna make it easy he needs to be
someone who can explain his position
yes in other words i think that almost
all of donald trump's positions were
reasonable he just didn't explain them
in a reasonable right exactly so he made
it easy for them by not
being clear and sometimes going on a
twitter tirade right the opposite trump
was very good at explaining things and
then just not doing anything
yeah that's more that's more what's
going on yeah we're gonna build a wall
and kick every muslim out and you're
like jesus i can get behind that and
it's like
okay sit down i can't do that somebody
can come in and not do that
i'm thinking of running for off i never
thought about running for office i have
thought about it honestly what would you
run for
uh
you're guaranteed to lose but why in
michigan too aren't you in texas
whitmer i'm sure he's just trying to
make up no i get it he's she's trying to
really he's
sticking it to the man again why would
you run in a blue stronghold as governor
it just seems like it would be
stupid right like wouldn't you run for
mayor run for something where you could
win and then
build off that that's what he said then
he said mayor but even to be a mayor you
have to most
replace is different but most places you
have to live in that city for at least a
year
some place i could actually make a
difference and here's what i would just
how about canada
oh yeah vancouver how about where you
came from go to vancouver
release the vox attack video be like you
know be like the
rabbit you know tell them something they
don't know about me but yeah the only
reason i would do it is because
what i am most afraid of you know we can
we can leave on this unless you have a
chat that you think when you hit what
i'm most afraid of
going forward with someone like donald
trump and i know donald trump is
an egotist and i know that donald trump
was in it for his own self-interest to
some capacity but he also stood up
and you're getting what are you doing
when you want to do selfless public
service is that what you want to
is that what you're doing i'm sorry name
me a selfless politician i'd like to
know who they are
a lot to lose right he came from the
private sector
he was an outsider and that was a huge
component
to the vitriolic hatred that he
experienced and i am afraid
that because of donald trump being held
his scalp being you know
hung up there basically not only donald
trump but they want to crucify anyone
who supported
donald trump like like the folk like the
uh the slave revolt and spartacus along
the road
just to let you know what happens if you
support an outsider all right bill maher
why don't you [ __ ] relax
okay dennis miller i am so concerned now
especially in the era of social media
where
everyone has stuff out there that can be
used against them
that people good people who actually
want to
change the country for good will be
afraid to run because they know
their lives will be destroyed their
reputation will be destroyed
their families will be dragged through
the mud because of the elite
so what he's talking about is he's
saying all these horrible things are
going to do this
are going to fall me but i'm i'm going
to do this for you
he's doing the typical crowder move
which is the
look what i'm doing for you look what
i'm willing to put myself through for
you
he's [ __ ] psychotic look what i'm
look what i'm gonna do for you
do you know how bad you know you don't
understand how selfless i am to do this
i'm not gonna do this as a publicity son
like stern did when he ran for president
i'm not going to do that this time it's
going to be for real i'm going to make a
real difference in [ __ ] i don't know
what town in michigan you plan to run in
even though you [ __ ] live in texas
and are from canada
political system you should run for the
mayor of south bend they love
you guys key west maybe
san francisco true but i was just making
the booty boot
butt fudge reference in class in
washington dc and so the only people
who will continue to live in that swamp
are the direct beneficiaries
of nepotism or being given a free path
so long as they play along together
says the guy whose dad runs his company
and who doesn't pay his employees
anything but
lets his dad make a lot of money off his
company yeah but if ndas were dollars
all his employees would be rich
[ __ ] millionaires well the only
reason i would ever consider this is why
i'm actually considering running is
because
i have nothing to lose i've made a lot
of mistakes
my flaws are open on for for everyone to
see
unfolded you do you do an exceptional
job of doing anything you can to
cover up nda's any [ __ ] flaw you have
yeah nda
you have ndas okay and you know what
i don't want people to feel like there
is the government
who rules over them the government is
meant to be ruled by people who
represent you it's meant to be rules
okay every [ __ ] wine mom mega person
on facebook we know we know all the
memes and you get it
thanks canadian guy i know how my
constitution works appreciate it
by people like you and i don't just mean
ivy league educated
harvard grads and lawyers how long
before landau just hates him
i think linda already hates him i think
landow's just getting paid better i
really believe that
and i'm not saying crowder pays well i
just think crowder pays better than
compound that must be
[ __ ] and it's cheaper to live in
texas than it is to live in new york too
that's the other thing you got to keep
in mind
it's crazy to think that he doesn't like
that
now i'm like really trying to think of
how little he made for cumia
like he must have made no money working
there
tank uh think tank elites i mean small
business owners
i mean people out there who maybe maybe
you run a construction
company stephen do me a favor why don't
you figure out what you're running for
before you
start the campaign yeah he's already
doing his speeches nobody's running for
you no idea what he wants to do and he's
like
ah america and the the truckers and
we're gonna bring the no seriously
construction workers yeah
like ditch diggers why you grab a
megaphone and a hard hat you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's staying in the rubble like [ __ ]
bush [ __ ]
we're bringing the automotive industry
back to detroit shut up i
i just hate him why is he wearing why is
he wearing that vest can someone explain
that to me
i'm so i know some of you guys watch
crowder can somebody explain what the
point of this was because all of his
employees checks bounced
last week
and they just he's afraid of them oh
[ __ ] it was the covers new album like
get rich or die grifting
and i'll buy a mug on all of those folks
out there to feel as though they can
represent their constituents
without fear of having their life being
destroyed and that is what i am most
worried about
with the fallout and the public
crucifixion of anyone including a lot of
good americans who love but he much like
jesus
is gonna put himself on the cross for
you when has stephen crowder ever
ever ever promoted or highlighted
anybody who's ever been censored
uh there was that one time he promoted
himself when he got censored so think
about that
bigot like not one
even slightly edgy brand
did he defend when they lost their thing
like he's so
full of [ __ ] like you said it's just
this like look what i'm doing for you
and it's like you're doing this for you
stop being stop being so disingenuous
their country in supporting donald trump
and that's the only reason
i have ever or would ever consider
running for an office
well that in north carolina that's
probably more the main thing
yeah felt i could make a quantifiable
difference
and i'd have to give all of this up but
you guys let me know what you think it's
not something wait you'd stop doing the
show
okay hey you know what let's do it i'll
be the campaign manager
for free crowd let's do it crap crowder
crowd
do it let's [ __ ] do it let's get him
elected
or in reality here's what he's doing
he's gonna go run in a really really
blue place that way he knows he's gonna
lose
so he'll keep doing the show while he
runs get free publicity get free
publicity and then go look guys i tried
but the system is rigged
if you buy some mugs next time i'll save
the country but that's what these guys
do like ever this is why they really
should limit like to work like or do
something with the requirements to run
for office because running for american
office has become
a way for people to just do another tip
just promote their [ __ ] brands like
everyone does this like everyone that
has a blog or a podcast or
is a porn star or failed actor like look
at california they always run for
governor and run for
and it's just it they use it as an
advertising platform and it's gross like
it really is gross
it's on the near horizon but it's
something that's been percolating
it's something that's circulating he's
going to do it he's going to give it all
up
you think you think dave landau wants to
hear that he just moved this entire
family to someone who's about to give it
all up to run for office
i don't give a [ __ ] he has a faux hawk
okay well that's fair
i'm not i did i'm never never in my life
is the thought could have passed my mind
what does dave landau think of this
hey what is the fauxhawk guy who hasn't
seen his family
for you for a year because he's too busy
working for kumia
what does he think so
um there is
something you're going to learn that
you're going to like because he does
bits he does these bits
and they're really funny and i haven't
showed you this one
dude i don't want you to i want you to
laugh today a little mike so you're
welcome okay
it's called how to train your joe biden
on crowder911
i don't think joe biden knows what he's
doing a physically inappropriate
politician
he's at the point where he gropes every
person that walks by
memes that's what he does does he
scrolls through his facebook
sees whatever the trump memes are and
then he does skits on them
havoc on the lives of his voters jump
at first i thought it was cool but then
he started kissing my neck and
sniffing because you know biden was
first of all but today they can't really
give her the nickname too cute
what real i missed that really
listen oh listen i mean
[Music]
it's like if you're gonna lie to me
right like if you're gonna insult my
intelligence and call this girl cute
fine whatever i guess it is a subjective
term and everybody has different taste
but when you write things like too cute
i can assure you
that there is no uh overabundance of q
there is no cute surplus
coming off this girl let's calm down
maybe it's ironic at calling a big guy
tiny
you know maybe like or like the tag team
too cool
either one of those guys was cool if
somebody says you should boogie bumper
says call her cute-ish
yeah her name should be uh maddie
my neck and sniffing hey
this joe biden was clearly out of
control and it was time for
is he doing a dog whisperer thing in
2020
what's the caesar milan reference he's
doing a dog whisperer are you [ __ ]
serious
crowner might be not only is crowd or a
hack which is fine because i'm a hack
it's fine but like he's a hack
he's like a 2012 hack which is like
really weird he's so behind yes
someone to do something about it
[Music]
quarter person of color garrett and his
co-worker maddie have been dealing with
a politician with no respect for
boundaries or personal space
hey corner black hey what seems to be
the problem well
that's a good accent too right that's
very good
just shut up all them jail's a horse
caesar milan it's pretty good dude it's
funny because it's like it's topical
dude
when was the last time that show ran i'm
gonna i bet you it probably still runs
but nobody's
watching it uh
dog whisperer okay so it was dog oh
caesar 9-1-1
is the new one that he has ah okay
cool
i'm trying i'm trying to dog whisperer
was the original show
and when do you think dog whisperer came
out
um has to be
at least 10 years ago oh four oh four
jesus
so 17 years ago want to know when it
ended
2012. remember when you said 2012. well
he did do the crowder 911. so i guess he
is doing this the new caesar milan show
caesar 911
it's not like you know it's like making
a queer eye for the straight guy
reference like i'm sure those guys are
still doing makeover shows but who the
[ __ ] knows who they are anymore
caesar 911
caesar 9-1-1 was on was in 2014
and it ended in 2016.
so it's still a five-year-old show yeah
it ended in 2016 was the last episode of
it
from what i'm seeing crowder is so
[ __ ] embarrassing
it's joe biden here he won't stop
sniffing and kissing people
it's a real problem yeah i've done
everything i don't know what to do okay
see
the first thing you did is right now
when he's you're very
tense you're giving off that energy and
you actually
is he really gonna do an entire
four-minute bit about bite and sniffing
people
like a filmed bit like you know i like
just joking around yeah dude it's he's
he wants to stretch his acting chops
show off his really dope hispanic accent
is the guy playing biden
is is that his dad is that crowder's dad
uh you know he kind of looks like from
this angle
he's john hughes the dad from uh
um home alone oh yeah yeah
dad from home alone yeah but the one
who's dead he died yeah i know
he was a good actor too yeah he kind of
ruled you're very tense
you're giving off that energy and you
actually encourage
that behavior i encourage you that's
right
okay oh what do i do the first thing we
need you to do
is get your jawbite into a calm relaxed
you imagine having this
sit there and sniff the quarter black
guy for this whole sketch
for 25 different takes
i i i know every time we talk about them
and whatever when we clip stuff and
people can get suicidal
yeah about that but people just that the
people like oh no he's actually really
funny
or the one that i see the most is people
like okay he's not funny but has changed
my minds are pretty good and
or my favorite at least he's doing
something for the movement
selling mugs yeah for the movement gonna
do that
with no talk no touch no eye contact
okay but by the way when people use that
weak ass argument at least he's doing
stuff for the movement
what is he doing besides what tom
mcdonald does which is marketing to that
movement and creating
content that will specifically make
people in that part of the culture war
enjoy things
that's not helping any movement right
helping
the movement is something like um chris
pratt
matthew mcconaughey people that are cool
people that we all
of a country as a country have
collectively decided and voted on and
said
these guys are cool right chris pratt's
cool
um matthew mcconaughey is cool and they
very
subtly by just being who they are
represent a certain part of culture that
people don't usually like and people
might
go wow okay you know mcconaughey is a
christian and chris pratt like that
those guys are kind of cool
nobody who's a normie who's not already
conservative
people that already watch hodge twins
videos no
steven crowder is there's no lefty
there's there's nobody that
has ever watched crowder that's not a
conservative that went
this is what i've been missing like you
know what i'm a conservative now if i
can get more content like this
so what is he really doing like stop
conflating
the people that market to right wingers
as
doing stuff for the movement you're just
selling mugs to the movement
it's again nobody no normie has watched
crowder and went that guy
is [ __ ] hilarious
yeah hey crowder let's see you have some
real go out to put do some blackface
no but the thing is is like he does a
lot of he pretends like he's doing this
stuff like making you believe what crowd
are saying like
crowder's not doing anything in any way
like crowder would never make the joke
that you made the first hour
which i disavow this available i
completely disa i'm not getting you back
for what the [ __ ] you did about seth
rogen you [ __ ]
so now i'm doing it to you i who
allegedly
maybe he's the one that aoc oh my god we
solved it cold case yeah
when the guy was coming did he go
because i think i have a suspect in mind
you just nailed it down to everyone that
went to berkeley
[ __ ] great mike
[Laughter]
right it's okay to drop the leaf it's
okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay okay
i see what i did is i do a small
correction
when joe biden goes in to kiss him see
i'm stopping the brain i do think that's
his dad
from escalating to a stay of sexual
assault
that's right i just feel bad for him i
don't think joe biden knows what he's
doing
my correction is not to her do you think
there's people that are like fans
and they watch these videos and they go
you know
i don't understand how quarter black
garrett keeps a striped face y'all
when you look at the comments like you
know seeing crowder dressed as caesar
milan has almost made me spit my soda
out highlight of my day
if that by the way if that's the
highlight of your day your
your life is being completely wasted
like that
uh you're you're you shouldn't you
shouldn't you don't deserve a full and
rich life
if you if any day in your 75 plus years
on this planet
the highlight of any one of those
thousands of days is seeing him dress to
caesar milan and going
this was the highlight like that's
that's a life wasted
it's 2 a.m and i just woke up woke my
wife up from laughing
uh fun fact they didn't need to hire an
actor biden just came and
was told to be himself yeah this this
2am and i just woke my
wife up laughing you should get divorced
like she should divorce you
uh crowder has been off the charts
hilarious with all the skits lately
has he off the charts off the chart like
can't even be
so what you're saying is they can't even
be measured in their hilarity
i can't believe they actually got joe
biden for this kid
quarter person of color garrett lol
that's really funny stuff guys this this
this skit should come with a warning
label do not watch with a full bladder
because you might oh mike didn't get the
joke because mike you might pee your
pants
oh i thought it was because i was gonna
whip my dick out and piss all over
everything
that's electronic in this room please
don't because that would be please don't
pm i think that would be
really the way to do it please don't be
my thanks just piss all over everything
that is crowded
these microphones we got more expensive
please don't just pee all over
everything
snap the brain out of it okay no
not your track it's okay okay that's
okay
no calm assertive karma sort of hey
hey see this the corner black is giving
off a tense
energy and escalating he's asking
himself is it joe biden
gonna kiss my neck with this huh
yeah it's a four-minute bit it's a
four-minute bit
this shouldn't have been a 30-second bit
good stuff though yeah that crowder sure
is irreverent
he really is he's he's next level if you
ask me
um it just kills me that people are like
he's he's
really she's funny man like i i can't
there are some people where i just like
your opinion on something will will make
me not like you
and crowder's one of those litmus tests
like if you think he's funny
i don't like who i there's no world
where we'd ever hang out
if you think crowder's funny